là plusieurs qui terminent leurs
vacances mais y en a d'autres pour qui
ça commence et parfois même en vacances
soit période de repos on est porté à
regarder son téléphone à répondre à des
appels et aussi des courriels
professionnels mais en a plusieurs qui
militent pour un droit à la déconnexion
on va parler avec marianne plamondon qui
est avocate en droit du travail bonjour
bonjour madame tout le monde bonjour
qu'est ce que c'est exactement ce droit
à la déconnexion on entend de plus en
plus au moulin en fait la loi française
a introduit un droit à la déconnexion
mais qui n'est pas une obligation de
résultat qui est une obligation de
moyens donc les entreprises ont été
obligées de mettre en place une
politique par lesquels ils disent aux
employés qui peuvent se déconnecter à
l'extérieur des heures régulières de
travailler durant les vacances par
contre il n'y a pas d'obligation comme
tel à l'employeur donc si par exemple
l'employeur appel l'employé l'employé a
le droit de réponse ils le souhaitent
donc ce n'est pas une obligation de
résultat de ne pas répondre exactement
comment ça se passe en france parce que
certains succès et c'est maintenant
s'est répandue parce que la loi donc la
loi sont les normes leurs lois sont les
nomme le introduit lorsqu'on aura fait
la loi sont énormes avec la ministre
dominique vien ça a été soulevée par
québec solidaire ça n'a pas été
introduit dans notre moi lois sont les
normes dont vous comme tel il ya pas de
ya pas de droit il ya les normes quand
même qu'ils appliquent ils énorme
travail prévoit clairement le droit aux
vacances et ça c'est un droit d'autres
publics dont on peut jamais y déroger et
le droit aux vacances signifie de
s'arrêter vraiment et de ne pas
continuer à répondre à tous les
courriels donc les emplois y ont droit
de vraiment comme on dit fermé et mettre
le bouton off sur leur téléphone
cellulaire leur ordinateur et de
profiter pleinement de leurs vacances et
toutes les études démontrent que le fait
de prendre des vacances aide ensuite à
la performance lors du retour des
vacances
oui parce que les nombres le v10
reckless on a le droit de se reposer
qu'est ce que ça changerait concrètement
qu ici également on est ce droit à la
déconnexion
en fait c'est que le doigt la quête des
connexions pour les vacances est prévu
parce qu'on a le droit aux vacances
mais quand on parle de la l'extérieur
des heures normales du travail
le droit québécois à l'heure actuelle il
n'y a pas de limitation et plusieurs
organisations qui ne paye plus
maintenant le temps supplémentaire parce
qu'on paye un salaire annuel
donc pour les employés de se retrouver
avec un droit de se déconnecter à partir
de 5 heures pile je la changerait
complètement exactement ça changerait
complètement l'organisation du travail
est-ce qu'on en est là je ne crois pas
l'autre chose aussi de toute façon ça
prendrait un changement législatif on
vient de revoir la loi sur les normes ça
faisait des années qu'on l'avait pas
fait on peut pas penser qu'on va le
refaire dans quelques années on peut
passer que les employeurs étant donné la
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre veulent innover
veulent créer des conditions de travail
exceptionnelles pour que les employés
soient bien au travail qu'ils aient le
goût de rester dans leur emploi qu'on
puisse les retenir et donc les empereurs
ont tout intérêt à mettre sur pied des
politiques de déconnexion et ça commence
dans les entreprises québécoises donc
une politique interne qui prévoit que
l'employé hall droit et oblige et il ya
le droit de se déconnecter dans
certaines circonstances
donc si ça c'est des politiques internes
c'est quoi ces chacune des entreprises
qui décident grosso modo ce qui se passe
entre 17 ans par exemple et 7 ans le
matin exactement donc à l'extérieur des
heures normales de travail pas
d'expectative de réponse immédiate de la
part de l'employé on lui permet de se
reposer parce qu'on était rendu dans
certaines entreprises avec certaines
pratiques excessives dont j'ai vu des
gens qui dormaient avec le téléphone sur
la table répondez milliards un certain
moment surtout danse avec la
globalisation des fois il ya des gens
qui travaillent avec différents fuseaux
horaires certainement faut laisser les
gens dorment y est ce que vous trouvez
les employeurs actuellement sont en
train de s'auto discipliner
il ya quand même une tendance là dessus
parce que veut pas la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre oblige les employeurs à
chercher à comment devenir un employeur
de choix pour pouvoir attirer les
talents et les garder et donc les
employeurs sont dans ce type de
réflexion l'art actuel
est ce que vous croyez qu'on est sûr
connecté on attend sont de plus en plus
que le téléphone c'est devenu une
obsession qu'on veut toujours répondre à
nos courriels vous travaillez là dedans
vous envoyez des colas yaoi aucun doute
il ya aussi beaucoup de codes et des
codes jurisprudence qui ont reconnu la
cyberdépendance comme étant un handicap
en vertu de la charte
donc vraiment que c est ce que s'il
reconnaît l oms je sais pas je pense
qu'il y avait des sages et ça je ne sais
pas mais chose certaine en droit
québécois ça a été reconnue la cyber
dépendance ne veux pas ça devient
vraiment les gens seront de la
difficulté à déconnecter et tout mais
toutes les études démontrent que pour la
santé pour le bien-être des gens c'est
mieux de savoir fermer
l'appareil pour pouvoir profiter
pleinement des vacances est son temps
personnel le temps famille il ya des
gens la maison qui nous écoutent sont
probablement en vacances alors c'est
quoi les biefs est vraiment de se
déconnecter complètement mais les lits
les études démontrent en fait que ça
diminue l'épuisement professionnel les
chances de maladie ça augmente la
productivité lors du retour au travail
est globalement les employés qui met une
balise claire entre le travail et la vie
personnelle ont généralement un meilleur
bonheur au travail donc s'annoncer pour
enfin on peut dire donc l'équilibré
entre les deux on est on est tous pris
date dans ses questionnements là mais on
n'a pas le choix de le faire parce qu'à
un certain moment aussi il pourrait être
heureux pour réussir au travail faut
avoir un certain équilibre de vie
est ce à ce défi merci beaucoup m rien
de l'abandon